joining us now house minority whip steve
scalise and founder of the committee to
unleash prosperity steve moore whose
newsletter is called the hotline steve
is the money guy let me start with you
they haven't released who's going to pay
for it who's going to access it how many
will access it and how it's going to be
paid for
what do we know about the cost of this
i've heard 300 billion but it seems like
a floating number
well pete i've got to tell you i wrote a
piece for foxnews.com on this yesterday
about how unfair it is and how fiscally
irresponsible it is i've never seen uh
people so angry about something you know
biden i think proposed this because he
thought it would be popular with some
voters but but i think he's laid an egg
here and politically now the big problem
with this with this bill is they don't
know how much it's gonna it's gonna cost
they estimate about 300 billion dollars
by the way as steve scalise knows just
two weeks ago they passed the bill
saying oh we're going to reduce the
deficit and now they pas they pass a
bill that is uh that is going to add
another 300 billion add it all up pete
and if you look in the 18 months that
joe biden has been in office now 4
trillion 4 trillion dollars of spending
debt and money printing and then they
wonder where did the inflation come from
and they have the gall to tell us
they're doing it to reduce inflation and
reduce the deficit and the debt in the
future as if the numbers add up uh
representative is this the new reality
uh that an executive with the stroke of
a pen through the administrative state
can effectively wield the power of the
purse i always thought that was meant
for the legislative branch what
can republicans or a new majority do to
reign this in
yeah pete and it's not the new reality
it's a parallel universe and you know
many are questioning including myself
whether that that's this even legal to
do joe biden himself was speculating
that it might be illegal about a year
ago when he was talking about doing this
yet he did it anyway they all know it's
going to add to the deficit and the debt
i'm seeing numbers that maybe it's over
500 billion dollars in deficit
spending in addition to what they did
last week again a 730 billion dollar tax
increase
plus 87 000 irs agents to go after
middle-class people all of this is by
the way going to increase inflation
inflation is driven by all the mad
trillions in spending you've already
seen add another over a trillion dollars
in new deficit spending just in a week
and look at what that's going to do and
all to do what to shift income about 85
percent of americans don't have any
student loan debt and they're going to
be paying for about 15
of americans who do you know is that a
wealth transfer and for what because
they didn't get a good education they
should go ask for a rebate from the
college not from the hard work and
taxpayers of america
steve moore talk to me about that wealth
transfer because it it there's a huge
chunk of americans who are about to pay
for a smaller chunk of americans for the
debt that they include where's that
money going from whom to whom
yeah great point and you know we have
half of the workers in america don't
have a college degree and so what this
bill this bill essentially would do
is take 300 billion dollars uh to people
with college degrees from people who
don't have college degrees and how in
the world is that
fair you know when i said that people
were angry about this pete what really
makes people angry is that we but this
isn't what america is about you play by
the rules and you get rewarded if you're
if you're not paying your debts you're a
deadbeat i mean that's what that's the
term i'm gonna i'm gonna say that if
you're not doing you sign the loan you
said you were gonna pay the money back
and you're not going to one other point
i want to make that i think is really
important um
pete i think this is the death of the
student loan program if they do this
because think about this pete who in the
world ever is going to repay a student
loan
i mean that the program steve scalise is
dead if they do this because the
incentives are never to pay your loan
and wait till they give you an amnesty
and you don't have to pay the money back
representative
you can respond to that is it the death
of student loans but also you're in the
business of policy and politics
democrats probably assumed this would be
wildly popular young voters inclined to
vote for them yet the backlash has been
massive
yeah it's horrible policy and horrible
politics only joe biden could do a
double whammy there where you're seeing
the left even go after this just as the
rights going after it you know stephen
moore talked about some great points
there too but when you think about why
there's a student loan program it's to
help people go to college graduate you
know look i went to lsu i paid in part
with student loans and i paid every dime
back what about the millions of people
who do pay their loans back what are you
telling them and don't forget they took
over they meaning the federal government
took over the student loan program under
obama to pay for obamacare and then you
saw a mushrooming by the way in student
loan debt because the federal government
was encouraging more student loan debt
because they needed to pay for this
massive growth
growth of a new program called obamacare
where is that going to be that means
they're just blowing a 500 billion hole
now and obamacare too and for what again
to take money from one group of people
and give it to another this is insanity
it's not legal i think you're going to
see challenges to it but the fact that
biden is willing to do it tells you a
lot about how misguided they are on
inflation on deficit and what's driving
all of these massive problems
and you know another point
go ahead real quick oh just quick why
aren't we holding the universities
responsible for some of this debt you
know they have 700 billion dollars of
endowment 700 billion dollars and why
aren't they using that money to lower
tuition for families and and if if a
school has a uh somebody went to the
school and they don't pay the debt the
debt back i think that the school should
be responsible for that money not the
taxpayer well i like that that's right
actual accountability for the people who
admitted the student
uh yeah i i that makes uh makes a lot of
sense uh the steve's delivering on a
thursday night steve moore congressman
steve scalise thank you so much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else